معنى من مدرمان مدير مكتب الجزيره للمسلم
الكباشي طبعا بيت البرهان استهدف بيت
حميدتي ستوته ما الذي يضيفه للمشهد
استهداف بيت الهادي ادريس من هو الهادي
ادريس وما الثقل الذي يتمتع به لكي يكون
هدفا لاي قصف
نعم زين
قصف منزل الهادي ادريس جاء في بيان اصدرته
الجبهه الثوريه منذ قليل على يد الناطقه
على لسان الناطق باسمها اسامه
اسامه سعيد
ولكن لم يتبين الاهداف قال البيان ان الذي
قصف بيت الهادي ادريس عضو مجلس السياده
رئيس الجبل الثوريه هي طائره حربيه
سودانيه ومضى البيان يقول ان هذا ادان هذا
بعنف وقال يجب ان تتجه كل الفرقاء الى
حوار بلا شروط لانهاء هذه الحرب بالطبع
لابد ان نفهم الذي يجري في سياقه المنطقه
التي يسكن فيها هذه ادريس وفيها منزله
منطقه كافوري هي منطقه كانت اليوم مسرحا
لعمليات ومسرحة
لقصف بالطيران خاصه منطقه الشرق النيل
ومنطقه كافوري وبالقرب من منزل الهادي
ادريس ايضا منزل عبد الرحيم الدقلو وهو
نائب حميدتين نائب القائد العام لقوات
الدعم السريع وهو الان في الميدان يقاتل
وهذا هذا هذا في سياق الصراع الذي يدور في
مناطق مختلفه المعارك التي تدور في مناطق
مختلفه ولكن سياسيا بالطبع الهادي ادريس
هو في في الموقع الموقف المضاد للموقف
الذي اتخذه الجيش هو من انصار الاتفاق
الاطار السياسيا وهو حليف للدعم السريع
وحمايه في هذا السياق السياسي ليس فقط
منزل الهادي بالطابعه الخرطوم كلها اليوم
هي معارك كروه فر بين الفريقين وخاصه في
منطقه
اليرموك منطقه جنوب الخرطوم منطقه الشجره
واليرموك والمدرعات هذه المنطقه
استراتيجيه لوجود هذه
المؤسسات العسكريه الهامه كانما اريد
بالهجوم على اليرموك اما ان تحيد او
استهداف البنيه التحتيه للتسليح السوداني
لتصليح الجيش السوداني ذلك ان هذا المصنع
من المصانع المهمه جدا التي تمد الجيش
السوداني بمختلف انواع الاسلحه كما انه في
منطقه استراتيجيه قريب من مستودعات الغاز
والوقود والى غير ذلك ولذلك منذ يومين
الحرب فيه كروه فر يقترب الدعم السريع من
هذه المنطقه ويدخل فيها احيانا ثم يرد من
الجيش وهكذا الى الان لم تنحسم هذه
المعركه في هذه المواقع الاستراتيجيه
مدير مكتب الجزيره من ام درمان شكرا جزيلا
لك